hello everybody
i'm grandmaster steven zerk
and welcome to insane in the end game
my theme for today is going to be
checkmate in the endgame and we're going
to see
this happen in some surprising positions
i'm going to start with some favorite
studies
that end in some very nice checkmates
and then we're going to see some
real world examples some practical games
checkmate either approved or cost either
gained or lost
a surprising half point or even full
point
so to start off i have this study some
of you might have seen it before
you have an obstacle bishop endgame
at first it might look pretty drash
it might seem like
the pawns are pretty easily blockaded
especially by black
if anything white's the one struggling
on the king side but here white has a
surprising resource
does anyone see what it is has anyone
seen this before
it turns out the black king is not as
comfortable as he might look
and if you're watching this after the
fact please feel free to pause and try
to solve these yourself
a lot of them are fantastic and quite
complex too
yeah so in this one it actually turns
out
that if we play h4 we have a very nasty
cage here yeah
so we actually need to set that up and
that is correct to start off
we play b5 kind of surprising it just
looks like a random gambit
if you don't see the purpose behind it
and black takes
white follows up with c6
and again this looks bizarre until you
realize just how much trouble the black
king is in
and now d7 the sole idea of these
gambits
is to force the black bishop to move
right to force black to take the spawn
if black doesn't if black plays
something like h4 and we'll see why he'd
want to do this in a moment
then we have this nice move bishop takes
g5
clear the way with check and get an
easily one end game
but if black takes the pawn does anyone
see how do we tighten the noose around
black's king
yeah simply play h4
and funnily enough despite black's five
extra pawns right g4 we simply made on
g5
can't he cannot escape takes and takes
and these two pawns in particular doom
black if either one were gone it would
actually be an easy win for black
but no matter what black does white's
next two moves are easy
moves up and checkmate
very nice just king and bishop mate in
the end game
there's one other try for black black
can try bishop e6 jack
the idea being to divert white's king
right if white takes the black king
escapes
and otherwise if king f6 then white's
bishop can no longer cover this h4
square
it white blocks his own bishop so what
would white do here
so king f6 and if black takes blacks
actually up six pawns
white spurns the free bishop again and
funnily enough just goes bishop e7
and suddenly if any one of these three
pawns were gone black would be winning
but once again there is no escape from
this checkmate now the mate just happens
on f8 instead
or if you prefer you can also mate on f4
yeah very nice finish
all right this next one
it wipes down some material for the
queen this ends in another classic
pattern
which some of you might have seen before
so this is again white to play and win
now there's some pretty crazy finishes
in this puzzle
so what to do here as white
so the first move i think is pretty
natural we can't let this king escape if
black's king gets to safety
if black's king runs to safety there's
not really hope of a checkmate we don't
have enough material
and of course black is well up on the
board so the first move is pretty forced
king f5 have to lock in black's king
black can only move the queen can't go
here because of mate can't go here
because knight f6 is made
so the only move for black is queen f8
and what to do now
so the first thought the most obvious
move might be to take this pawn
which does win the queen black's king is
trapped but after takes takes
we don't get a checkmate we get a
stalemate
so that's no good
what can we do here instead
yeah knight takes f6 is the most natural
move here but it indeed does not work
but here there's a surprising resource
it ends in a pattern some of you might
have seen before
i've seen several different studies end
with this checkmate
yeah knight g7 surprising move because
black gets the knight
we have bishop e8 but it seems like
black's covering the mate
and for the moment he is but suddenly it
turns out after bishop takes
pawn takes we have this funny checkmate
we take f6
black's only move his g5 we come to f5
and once again black is in a very
painful zx1
only legal move is g4
and there's our checkmate
yeah if you do a lot of if you do a lot
of studies especially end game studies
this will not be the last time and
perhaps not even the first time you've
seen this checkmate pattern
i've seen a couple others that end the
same way
yeah well spotted chess king
king f5 like i said very painful zig
zone for black
he's even from here black just has to
march the jeep on up the board to his
doom
once again if any black pawn were
missing it would be at least a draw for
black
so we're seeing a theme here of black's
own pawns
dooming his king
alright this next one is quite tricky
this is one of my favorites though this
is a great casparian study
and it's once again white to play and
win
so obviously white's down a lot of
material but black's king is again
not in a particularly
not in a particularly healthy spot i
might say
so these positions solving studies like
these i would say
is very good for overall calculation and
visualization especially
these are some tough puzzles in the
second part of this
of this lecture we'll see some real game
positions
including some very nice checkmates
there as well
but these i think since you have to be
very resourceful in these positions and
you have to see things very carefully
because the resource is surprising it's
not something you can learn just by
memorizing tactical patterns
so i think these puzzles and solving
them especially really
tests your ability to see the board in
your head to visualize it
and then to find resources that way
because you can't really rely on
previously learned tactical patterns
and in particular a lot of my teachers
too a couple of them would give
puzzles like this to solve as a warm-up
at the beginning of a lesson
and besides all that of course they're
just a lot of fun
so here in this one
yeah the idea here first of all we have
to start creating a mate thread if black
takes away these pawns if we give black
a little time
we're not going to get anywhere
if knight e4
i mean we do have ideas of taking on f6
but the problem the problem with f6 i
would say first of all black has rook
takes f4
this covers all the mate threats
and after takes black can take here for
example and the king escapes
so we do need to bring the right the
bring the knight in that's the right
call
as it turns out though we don't want it
on f6 we want it on g7
and 98 is the first move
so the idea is after most moves by black
if for instance black takes a pawn
we have knight g7 and bishop f5 mate
so we have a pretty strong threat based
on knight g7
and here it's pretty tricky for black
if f5 for example to try and give the
king some squares
white can simply take it and mate with
knight g7 next
so black goes king g6 this is the best
try
and now the problem is now it's tough
because if knight g7
now black has f5 and the king escapes to
f6
so here white has to be pretty creative
and the
and what white has to do here to mate is
why i like this study so much
so again maybe take a moment and see see
if you can find this because this is
crazy
so first of all white goes h5
and we're going to see why in a moment
if black takes with the king again we
have the familiar pattern
knight g7 bishop f5 mate
so black takes with the rook
and now f5 check once again
we can't allow knight g7 f um sorry f5
from black
the king escapes same with g4 f5 or g4 g
takes f4
so white has to go f5 check
as we're seeing these sacrifices as
we'll see
are actually actually the seal black in
his doom in a way
rook takes f5
and now g4 and we want to
lock the black king in if we play knight
g7 to go for mates
black has g4 and makes some breathing
room so the whole idea of these moves is
to seal black's king in
g4 once again there's no f5 there's no
h5 no way to make a square
we're threatening bishop takes f5 mate
so black has to move the rooks a to c5
and then the crazy part bishop f5
check the rook has to take the bishop
and knight g7
with mate next move
so look at that white gave away white
gave away all their pieces
but the end result is a checkmate with
the last knight in pawn
and once again if any black piece were
taken off the board black would be
winning because the king could escape
them
or white couldn't do the checkmate
yeah the final position for this one
alone is worth the price of admission
for me
yeah knight g7 and one of these two pawn
moves will be checkmate next move
all right so next up
all right this is from a study by couple
in this position i could
i could quite possibly see in a real
game it's we're heading more towards
realism for the moment
i got a couple more studies and then the
games in this one again it's white to
play and win
these pawns are a pretty pressing threat
it would be easy to think in a game that
for instance b2 actually threatens to
win
in a game it might be easy to conclude
that you just have to accept the draw
give up the knight stop the pawns with
the bishop
something like bishop takes c4
but you're not going to win the game
that way
and it might even be surprising that
checkmate even comes into play in this
position at all
but okay how to try and win this white
what would you do
so we have to bring the knight in knight
b6
right you have to bring the knight to
safety too because if the bishop is tied
to the knight white can't stop the pawns
black plays b2 if black plays c3 white
just cleans up the pawns
and the bishop and knight can easily
block 8 on b1
so white to play and win so b2
only way to stop this pawn is knight d5
and knight c3
and here it gets tricky
because black plays king c5
and it really seems like black's going
to get at least one piece for these
bonds right white's king is
way is way far afield
and indeed after most possible moves if
for instance white goes after this b2
pawn
black actually gets a draw with the c
pawn white has no way to set up a good
blockade here
if white could control c2 with both
pieces this would be an easy win but
it's just too slow right these two moves
would win but white doesn't have time
and sure enough after this
you know something let's even just go
here black wins the night with a draw
so in this position the only winning
move
is knight b1
and we'll see why in a moment the idea
is now when black plays king b4 right
black's trying to get the pawns forward
it doesn't come with tempo so white goes
king b6
after c3 white has bishop d3
and maybe now maybe someone can spot the
mate pattern now
after king b3 now it seems like the
pawns are going to get there it seems
like the pawns are
going to at least draw could even start
worrying about a win
what does white do here after king b3
you can't stop c2 at least not in a good
way
but king b5 and after c2
suddenly we don't stop the pawns at all
checkmate
and there it is
all right one more study another one of
my favorites
and then we'll get to some some very
nice games
now for those a couple of you asked
where i got these from
a couple books i highly recommend are
tactical chess endings by john nunn
um doveretsky's endgame manual of course
pretty high level
but the section on checkmate is a lot of
fun
and then just some study collections of
my own that i have
actually have to give thanks to
grandmasters vita zorya for
sending me some of these studies
this next one again it might be seems
surprising that checkmate's going to
come into play
in this position white's up a piece but
this is not a winning material
this is not a winning balance of
material
right if black saves these and white
saves these it's a draw
so after say knight e7 bishop d6 draws
for example knight e3 with the idea of
checking here also draws
that's why we have to take action here
if we want to try and win this game
so what can we do
yeah this one there isn't much choice to
try and win
yeah it's worth noting white has to save
the bishop bishop and knight vs king
is a win so we can always give up one
night
but that's easier said than done right
if white takes a piece black takes on g6
and white's dropping another piece with
a dead draw
so the only try for white actually is
knight h8 check
it has to try and save some pieces
because of knight e5
black snaps it off with the bishop and
again
this material balance is a draw
bishop knight versus knight is not too
difficult
so knight h8 king g8
right black has to try and get one piece
it's worth noting
while two nights might be a draw two
nights might be a draw but
this is a win so black has to try and
get some material back
and black has a pretty clever resource
here king g8
king takes g2
if king takes h2 black has knight e3
with a double threat of knight g4 check
and team takes h7
either getting rid of the bishop or
winning a piece with a draw again
so white takes on g2
and for a moment it actually seems like
white's just winning
right like two nights against the king
is a draw as you probably know
but with the extra bishops on the board
something like this
this is actually a win for white
so now now the burden is on black to
find
find trickery find some complications
and black has this
goes bishop f4
all right trying to trap this knight if
the knight comes to g5 again we have a
draw
and now we have a bunch of counter
punching white goes knight g6
right k7 knight f4 is not acceptable for
black bishop knight is a classic win
so after knight g6 black finds bishop h6
and knight g5
and again it seems like white saved
their pieces right everything's away
from the king
but we have more tricks up black sleeve
bishop g7
and so hang on this bishop trade leads
to a draw
two nights but what if white let's say
white moves the bishop over
let's say white plays bishop d8
what is black thinking of here why isn't
this just a win
normally bishop and two knights versus
bishop is a win
but what does black have in mind
yep chest king is on point today bishop
f6
and suddenly we have a stalemate if
white takes
we have a draw if black's allowed to
capture these pieces
white has one try with an id7 check
right trying to save the bishop and the
knights
but after this i can try knight h7
but it's just not good enough the best
way to get here is two nights
again with a draw
so this position is actually drawn white
has no good way to avoid a drawn engine
but instead of bishop d8 if white's
thinking ahead if white sees this coming
why can turn it around in a surprising
way knight checks
black has to go to h8 if black goes to
f8
we check we take black can pick
whichever knight they want either way
we're again getting bishop and knight
against king
so the king has to go to h8 we do knight
f7
king h7 and now the bishop comes back to
h4
but you'll notice this is actually the
exact same
setup as before just rotated 90 degrees
remember the white bishop was on d8 or
sorry just mirrored
just mirrored and again black goes for
this trick bishop f6
again it seems like a draw but there's a
subtle difference here
that enables white to win this position
bishop f6 again so what can white do
here
why is this winning when it wasn't
before when it wasn't with the bishop on
d8
yeah the white king's going to come into
play so knight g5 is the only try
again you can't allow you can't give up
a knight you can't allow a bishop train
black again goes for king h6 right if
black goes somewhere like g7 if black
goes king g7 we can just save this
knight
this is winning so black has to try king
h6
i'm trying to target this knight as well
again with a fork
but what's the difference here
right after knight g8 black again has
king h5
just like in the other position black's
king went to e8 and got white's bishop
so knight g8 king h5
and what do we have here
this time thanks to white's king white
actually can take on f6
and i did say two nights against the
king is a draw
99.9 of the time that's the truth
but suddenly thanks to our king
look at this one in a million checkmate
with two nights
and white wins so if you're playing
black and you see this coming
you could always try and test your
opponent's bishop and knight checkmate
skills
yeah this is a very nice forced mate
all right with that let's jump into some
real games
this first one so again this is actually
from a fairly typical game
fairly typical two bishops first bishop
and knight in game
generally speaking two bishops greatly
outshine a bishop at night
in most end game manuals you'll find at
least one example
of an end game that's basically won off
this advantage alone
the bishops are just a much better team
and here i mean hear why it's in very
good shape
you can see white has better pieces
black's kind of passive
here white has good winning chances and
white played bishop e4
right trying to activate the bishop
creating some threats
maybe expecting to induce upon weakness
with g6
but what's the problem with this move
what did white miss what did white fail
to consider
so this is what bishop b4 is what white
played in the game
you're absolutely right as it turns out
g5 then bishop g4
you could play although i think you i
don't think you're winning anything for
it
it's an idea it's certainly better than
the game
it's definitely it definitely would have
worked out better than the game does but
what's the problem with this move
as it turns out this was literally
white's worst legal move
there we go so you could play knight f4
and get some play
so i mean there's in a typical endgame
you might play g6 you might play knight
f4 you might even think about knight g5
but as it turns out there's a stunning
resource here that white no doubt
completely missed
b5 yeah b5 from black
all right i see a couple people spotted
it and suddenly
far from white pressing the game is over
no matter what white does bishop b7 is
made
next move from black can even be
pre-moved
so white resigned on the spot
so like i said if you're talking about
other moves than bishop e4
well you are correct that they are
better than bishop b4 so this is
actually just meeting two
all right well spotted
this next one we have a pretty equal
rook end game i'll say equalish
this position blacks up a pawn but
white's pieces are much better placed
this rook keeps black's work passive and
cuts off black's king at the same time
so black came up with one last idea in
this position
black played f4 check
and now let me ask you where would you
move white's king
you're playing white and black uncork's
f4 check
what to do
yeah so the most natural move yep a lot
of king e4
most natural move is king e4 right and
indeed king e4 is what white played in
the game
and then black played rook d6
so what do you do now
wait to play
so if white plays rook takes a7
if black plays king e6 and suddenly
there's checkmate
suddenly after king e6 white had to
resign
because the only way to stop rook d4
checkmate is something like rookie 7 or
rook a6 giving up the rook
so there it is game over
so after king e4 rook d6 is pretty
stunning blow
if if you trade rooks unlike the rook
end game this pawn in game is lost
black simply moves the king and white
gets looks long tier
there's just nothing good for white to
do
the king moves over this leads to a
promotion of the f-pawn
if the king moves back white gets
zig-zwang
and the f3 pawn will drop
yeah so pretty clever idea from black
very easy trap to walk into
and a pretty quick turnaround in the
game
yeah so if white plays king e2 okay
white's a little worse
but at the same time with a rook this
strong white absolutely should not lose
yeah king e4 rook d6 and white resigned
yeah if you think that one's brutal wait
till you see this next one
so in this next one again as white it's
white to move here
actually to start off as white again
you're up a piece this position is
absolutely undoubtedly winning for white
how would you convert this position
well you'd still have to play out the
draw in that rook end game before yes
but it would definitely be doable i
think there's a comfortable margin there
so how is white to win this winning
position
and there's more than one correct answer
here actually quite a bit more than one
yeah g3 works the simplest way the
fastest way
is to just move the rook over and then
just push the h-bomb
and this just ends the game actually
there's no good way for black to stop
this pawn
some of you're suggesting many other
ideas bishop b3 should be winning bishop
c4 should also be winning
yeah lots of good moves here to be
honest even if it were black to move
here
white would be winning in the game
though in the game white decided i
should take care of this a pawn right
this apon is the biggest problem i have
on this board it's black's
it's the biggest danger black can pose
to me so in the game white decided to
double on the a file with rook ha7
and what did black do now can anyone
spot it black to play
white's threatening rook takes a4 check
so there's no time for subtleties
so rookie one and g4 are both ideas to
set up a mating that
right both threaten me the problem is
again white's threatening this check
with
with a trade so after say rookie one
white takes on a4 and there's no time to
check me
because this is check and this is lost
so rookie one's a natural move but it's
too slow
all right we have the answer so instead
of rookie one black is faster
rook h1 and this was the game
continuation
white has to take and king g3
and white was forced to resign this is
going to checkmate
lights up a rook and a bishop but the
pieces are too badly organized
yeah from a clear piece up to
resignation in two moves
pretty tough finish
all right this next one was a classic i
would say
sim again very strong grandmaster
against bronstein
and one of the best players to never be
world champion
and did this one we see that black while
black's down significant amount of
material
black's of course about to turn the
tables with a promotion
so the question is as white
is white what do we do do we go for some
kind of perpetual with the queen
or can we find something more
what else can white do here
yeah so knowing the theme is checkmate
could try to bring in this bishop
so after bishop h6 though black's queen
covers g7
and g6 so here black can promote
and there's no checkmate because the key
squares are covered
on the right track though
instead of bishop h6 simeon found this
very nice move
bishop g5
this is they said this looks kind of
crazy
but it's the only winning move let's
talk about why
so we'll see what happens if black
promotes but first let's see what
happens if he doesn't
so if black takes the bishop with the
queen
this does stop the checkmate but it
abandons the h pawn
white goes check and check
picks up the pawn with an easily winning
queen in game two pawns up
so this is not an option
if black takes with g5 the f5 pawn comes
in with f6
and again black has no moves no checks
they're all covered by the white queen
and white is going to check mate on g7
so the only good try left for black
black could try the queen end game but
it's completely lost
only try for black is to promote
and this is what bronstein did but as it
turns out
all right white has to mate very quickly
otherwise these two queens
will find a mate or a queen trade
instantly
but we'll see simicon was up to the task
check
there's a few different ways of doing
this there's a lot of different move
orders
we're going to see first he grabs the
f-pawn with check
if king e8 queen e7 is mate so king g8
is forced
queen d8 check
and check and now the queen comes to e8
and here bronstein actually resigned
because he saw what was coming
there's no escape from the mate even
with the two queens the queen and bishop
are too fast
so if king g7 there's check with f6
and then i'm made on g7
and if king h7 the queen and bishop do
the job
checkmate
so after queen e8 bronstein resigned
bishop g5 though was a very nice find
all right let's see this next one is
very sneaky
actually this one is in this one is in
both devretsky's end game manual
and another book i'm rather fond of fond
of john nunn's chess puzzle book
it was actually john nunn that
originally spotted the win here
so in this position it's white to play
lights up a piece
as you can see this a pawn is pretty
terrifying
so it turns out you can talk about
playing for a draw there's some
repetitions white can play for
but there's a pretty stunning resource
in the game white actually played knight
e7
white played 97 with the hope that black
would play a2
and then king h6 and black gets the
queen
but white checkmates
but as it turns out black has
this nice move which he spotted f6 check
and after king takes it turns out
after king h7 white has a hard time
controlling this square
white has a hard time punishing the
black king here
and after knight f5 black can go a2
and white's just too slow to check mate
white played knight g6
there's no hope of a mate anymore but
this is a clever try after knight g6
if black promotes suddenly white goes
king f7
and there's no mate but now we're not
talking about a mate for white and
despite the extra queen
black cannot stop this perpetual check
with knight f8 g6
and this is actually a draw
in the game though black was on his toes
and after knight g6
found this nice way to break the
perpetual with knight d4
and despite the extra piece white is
lost
right white can grab the knight but then
black gets a queen and otherwise there's
just no hope of a checkmate there's no
way to set anything up anymore
so a nice a nice spot by black
but as it turns out there is a win in
this position
and it has something to do with what i
said mentioning that this h7 square
is kind of the tough point for white
the only winning move kind of surprising
it's actually king h6
yeah a couple of you mentioned this and
it is correct
the idea is pretty simple though right
after a2 white simply wants to control
g8 knight e7
and then get the checkmate just in a
different order
so black goes king g8
but now white goes knight d7
if a2 we get we end the same way check
and it comes back to e5 and there's our
checkmate
if black goes f6
right trying to escape this way
the king cuts off the escape again black
can try to promote
blacks out of other ideas at this point
but white checks white takes on f6
and again black is cornered checkmate
yeah as it turns out after king h6
there's nothing black can do
another pattern this kind of pattern
comes up comes up in other end games as
well f6
check this time white doesn't mate with
the knights but this time white plays
king g6
and this time the h-bomb does have its
say
black promotes but again the white h
bone marches forward
and this time white does get a queen
checkmate
yeah f6 is as good to try as any but
there's actually no escape after king h6
yeah very nice finish
he said full credit to john nunn who
originally spotted this win
so yeah the whole point really i mean in
part a lot of it's just calculation but
the logic behind it is that black's king
actually does a remarkably good job
hiding on h7
in a lot of the lines and you can look
at other moves you know king f6
etc the king h6 is the only one
all right now this next one
again from a real game and again it
might surprise you that it's
that's in this lecture because it seems
like a fairly typical end game
so in this point position we have rook
for bishop and pawn so we can perhaps
press and what do we do here is right
how should we play out this end game
we do have the material advantage but
black has some threats of their own
this a pawn is strong and if we take it
black's going to go after the g pawn
in the most obvious move right the move
that you'd usually play in the end game
is rook a5
but here after king g3 there's no way to
guard this pawn right rook a2 is covered
by the bishop
it does actually you can verify with
table bases this is not an easy draw for
black
not by any means but after something
like this
black is holding
alright and once again chess king with
the call
rook g6 and amusingly black's king is
completely helpless
right the king can't escape anywhere if
black does what might be the most
obvious course of action and the first
one you should check so let's say black
just starts pushing the a pawn
e3 but hang on a3 king f4 a2
so we go rook g3 right we want to
checkmate with rookie h3 if black
promotes that's what we'll do
but now what now what happens when black
goes bishop e6
what do we do here this probably reminds
you actually this might look familiar
after a couple of the previous puzzles
all right still rook h3 the bishop has
to take
and once again checkmate was upon
good game
well spotted so after rook g6 if black's
looking ahead black might think to cover
with the bishop
something like bishop b2 king e3 and
bishop g4
but now we don't we definitely don't
want black's team to escape if black
gets here and gets this pawn we suddenly
have to talk about whether we're better
at all
so best here is again king f4 and now
after a4
what's our plan of attack here
after a4 how should we play this out as
white granted in this position
our king position is so much better than
blacks that we're winning in general
but there is an elegant way to win this
an elegant plan
i should say
yeah we bring the rook around and again
we play for checkmates
rook g5 rookie 5 is indeed winning yeah
there's several good moves the key is
that you have the right idea
that you want to play for checkmate on
these squares
like there's there's several ways to
execute it and rook g7 e7 also works
another way is just rook d6 again with
this idea after a3
of root d3 and the same checkmate
if black's a little more stubborn and
tries bishop b2
then we play rook d2 and the bishop is
dominated
right black has to cover this square or
else we checkmate
black has to be prepared for rook d1 or
else we'll check mate here
so the only try for black here is bishop
f1 to
deal with these two squares but now
white simply goes rook f2
and again after these bishop moves white
again has rook f3 h3
well if black takes on g2 this endgame
is an easy one
yeah and white wins rook g6 is a very
nice resource
all right so for and for one last thing
for today
i'm actually i'm going to give you guys
an exercise that i was given once upon a
time
i think it's pretty interesting and the
way this puzzle works
so you want a position set up a position
where white has king knight and pawn
black has king and queen so those five
pieces are on the board
it's black to play with the king and
queen black is not in check but white is
winning
so this is us this is actually a
surprising exercise i find in several
ways
but very interesting again white has
king knight and pawn
against black's king and queen black's
not in check
and it's black to play but white wins
and when i when i give this to people
when i've given this to other people as
an exercise yeah there's no pieces on
the board yet
i'll put them on in a second but this is
more an imagination exercise
because you have to the point of this
puzzle is to figure out where the pieces
are
and i said if you're watching this if
you're watching this after the fact feel
free to pause
i'll be showing the solution in a second
when i give this exercise to people a
lot of times people will try
basically to corner the queen and find
some way to win it by cornering it with
white's pieces
or they'll try and promote but it turns
out neither of those strategies is good
enough
if you corner the queen or try to
promote black can just give up the queen
for your pawn
so the key to winning this is actually
to find a position
where black can't give up the queen for
the pawn at all you know either before
or after it promotes
and the only way to do this is actually
to set up a checkmate idea
so i'm going to spoil it here i said
feel free to pause or if you want to
take some time and try to figure it out
but this is the only way
this position here
it can be mirrored so you can put the
pawn on b7 king on b6
you switch the black queen to h5 so you
can mirror it the way you could any
chest position
but apart from that there's no other
solution
so this surprising one where it's not in
the short term about trapping the queen
or promotion at all it's the only win
and it's because you have this checkmate
threat of knight f6
and as it turns out there's just nothing
good black can do
the screen is not well placed to give
any good checks
these distract these diversions don't
work because the knight covers the pawn
and after anything else white plays
knight f6
again black has no choice but to take
otherwise he's mated
and white wins the pawn in game
so just an exercise i'm fond of it's
not the kind of solution people expect
when the problem is presented like i
said they usually expect
either the queen to be trapped or white
to promote and they expect the wind to
come that way
but it turns out neither of those is
good enough because sacrificing the
queen for the pawn is enough for a draw
so going for a checkmate with the knight
is actually the only solution
alright so nice work on all those guys
hope you all enjoyed the puzzles
that's all i have for today
yeah great work again just king
so no other solution known or is there
proof of no other solution existing
i don't know a formal proof that being
said
i would bet good odds that there is no
other solution
because similar positions and any queen
traps fail pretty miserably
but it's worth it's worth a look like i
said give this to some other people and
see how they approach the problem
all right thanks again everyone